how's the family good good are they good
yeah what's your daughter's name again
peep peepa pea how is she great great oh
that's great I have noticed that we
welcome thank you I've noticed we've
been having a lot of conference room
meetings and I'm wondering if perhaps
those are a bit um disruptive yes no I
don't think they are I think the
meetings are very important okay maybe
we should talk specifically
let's do okay yesterday we had a meeting
about planets well to be fair Jim
James jimothy to be fair jimothy the
that sounds weird are you okay with
being called Jim I am all right Dwight
what is your middle name
danger something with a K Kurt wow so
sad that I know that what do I write
under reason for
visit concussion
what did you write
nothing I wrote bringing someone to the
hospital Sam get my luggage I forget it
brother Samuel you are such an idiot you
are the worst assistant ever and you're
disgusting dged wait who's
dged here's what we think happened
Michael's sidekick who all through the
movie is this complete idiot who's
causing the downfall of the United
States was originally named Dwight but
then Michael changed it to Samuel L
Chang using a search and replace but
that doesn't work on misspelled words
leaving behind one twigged and Dwight
figured it out oops DW i g
HT hey you know what Dwight maybe we
should get our photo ID taken together
that doesn't make any sense well saves
time you know cuz we could just meet in
the parking lot every morning walking
together perfect smart SM
no I never smile if I can help it
showing one's teeth is a submission
signal in primates once someone Smiles
at me all I see is a chimpanzee begging
for its
life this came out really
well there you
go this is humongous I am not a security
threat and my middle name is Kurt not
fart what did I all
right there's my
girl noticed you handing out some
shekels how would one get on that train
that was pum for Philadelphia oh that
town smells like cheese Stakes that town
is full of
History Andrea is the uh office
you'll get used to
her
Creed Jim has got it bad for Pam oh
which one is
Pam sweet St dude who you supposed to
be Dave listen I got the answer you
declare bankruptcy all your problems go
away Creed Bradon has never declared
bankruptcy when Creed Bradon gets in
trouble he transfers his debt to William
Charles Schneider I really want to come
out good night Mary
Beth
spamster
um Pam plus spam plus hamster right Hey
Big Tuna you're single right mhm yeah I
am pretty hot
huh she's completely
crazy steer clear big
tuna H for open
Waters okay
okay I ate a tuna sandwich on my first
day so Andy started calling me Big
Tuna I don't think any of them actually
know my real name Big Tuna is a super
ambitious guy you know cut your throat
to get a head type of guy but I mean I'm
not threatened by him I went to Cornell
you ever heard of it I graduated in four
years I never studied once I was drunk
the whole time and I sang in the AC
capella group Here Comes
Treble what's going on no nothing
nothing Michael just saying hi the tall
guy got engaged pamama ding
dong listen you're cute there's no
getting around it so I don't know if you
like country music but I was thinking
maybe one of these days we can drive out
to a field crank up some tunes smoke a
few
macanudos maybe even toss a disc
around wow are you listening to what
he's saying R trining new system youth
I'm telling you this kid is the Grim
Reaper you deal with this or you me
Sammy philis the chicky hit with a car
were
goners uh excuse me these are expensive
collector's items okay do you have any
computer games no I don't have computer
games on my work computer that would be
inappropriate yeah Merith doesn't have
any either it's so lame here you call
your mom Meredith that's very
disrespectful whatever okay you can
refer to me as Mr shroot that's your
name Mr Poop shroot Mr shroot Sure Mr
Poop this is how I got squeaky
from no small talk just show her who's
the boss just go right in and kiss her
okay it sounds risky have I ever stared
you wrong
Jim wait what
read cre a sick of looking at the
redhead all day and wants a seat facing
the
receptionist night I guess you really
are the boner champ did he tell you how
I got the name no spring sing 95 got
completely ripped on bud
dries I had sex with a
snowman I just went at that thing cold
would have stopped most people but I
stayed locked in you know took the face
off just seemed easier that
way so there I am minding my own
business and Darnell offers me three
bcks all I got to do is walk by Andy and
go like this Darnell's a chump I would
have done it for anything I've done a
lot more for a lot of less the fire guy
the fire guy fire the guy Hey
Kevin that's really funny it's great to
see you Kev you too I'm keeping a list
of everyone who wrongs me so when I'm
back on top they'll be
sorry Kevin just made the list who's
Holly that is a great question Aaron how
do you describe cribe somebody who is at
the same
time an old friend and was a
lover and was a complicated part of my
past and maybe just maybe a part of my
future wow she's one sassy black lady
team building on this side of the room
Stanley Phyllis Jim Ted Elroy on this
side of the room Pam Meredith Phyllis
Creed he never called a meeting you will
will be called plop what why cuz you're
always taking dumps no I'm not come on
everybody defecates relax plop problem
solved everyone space orphan and
Princess nink poop are off to rescue
Michael happy birthday to game oh get
out Skeleton
Man anybody have his name Quick yes it's
Eddie it's not it's not Eddie it's uh
it's Evan or Hank his name is Hank oh
guys his name is not Hank it's uh is it
Edgar in the parking lot today there was
a circus copy did tricks on the Highwire
a lady tried to give away a baby that
looked like a cat there was a Dwight
impersonator and a Jim impersonator a
strong man crushed a turtle I laughed
and I
cried not bad for a day in the life of a
dog food company hello hello this is
Dwight fruit from the dunder mlin Paper
Company wow that's great cuz I need
paper excellent then you are in luck
because we are having a limited time
offer only on everything wow this is my
lucky day ask him his name what is your
name sir I am Bill
butlicker really that's your real name
how dare you my family built this
country by the way our prices have never
been lower you have to talk louder never
been lower louder son buter our prices
have never been lowered stop it
he that is totally inappropriate you
never yell at the client you never you
listen to me sir here we go the three
words I would describe you as is
aggressive and definitely difficult Mr I
rate right now please give me another
chance Mr but licker me the phone I have
to put you on with my boss well I should
hope so who is this hello this is
Michael Scott regional manager well this
is William M butlicker hello Mr
butlicker how may we help
you